kyle brandt of good morning football and
also of ten questions with kyle brent on
spotify and ringer his guest
is in fact tim robbins he teased it last
week
good to see you kyle brent how are you
sir
there's no rich eisen that cracks me up
more than unapologetically pissed off
jet stage
the long island comes out doesn't it
well i'm from staten island but it all
it is that's all good it's still an
island it's just much more it's more
pack impact it's more impactful you know
how are you doing right now
[Laughter]
that was a giant fan who called in
prayer prior to the season
jets fans you know i'm i'm here in in
the state of new york
and i see them and you can tell it's
like you know how you're if you're
walking down a sidewalk and you see
someone coming and you cross the street
to stay away from them
that's what it is they're so ornery and
they so want to punch someone
and they i think that one is pretty much
the head coach but i don't want it to be
me
i avoid the just fans now wide berth
would you want le'veon bell on the bears
kyle what do you think about that one i
think
the running back position is my favorite
in the game i think he's unbelievably
talented and i don't want him
anywhere close to a team that i'm
rooting for i don't want
matt nagy two weeks after they signed
le'veon bell
to have to answer questions from the
chicago media about yeah coach
le'veon liked several tweets uh that
said he wasn't getting the ball enough
your thoughts on that
get the hell outta i don't want to deal
with that no
way le'veon bell last year with the jets
did not have a run of 20 yards 20 yards
there's many many many people who have a
28 i don't need 60. i don't even need
40.
if you're that good you got to give me a
20 yard i don't care who's blocking for
you i don't think the skill is there
and i think the pain in the butt factor
is high
i wish him well but no not on the bears
and i don't think they will kyle
in the first hour brockman and i went
back and forth trying to fill out us
a poll question on twitter with four
teams we couldn't we barely got to four
teams
and we we went bears patriots just
because you know bill likes taking
somebody from the jets and and uh
winning championships with them i'm not
saying that
you know darrell rivas is the same as uh
le'veon bell but you
i think you're picking up what i'm
putting down yeah chargers because
they're so
banged up and texans those are the only
four we could come up with am i missing
any or
or well i just saw some uh really bad
news about the broncos running back
situation so maybe and
maybe them but listen the leviant
thing's fascinating this is a guy who
said
i screw it i'm sitting out i'm going to
try to be
a well-intended joan of arc for the
running back position
probably cost him some money definitely
cost them some wins
he's already getting paid so i don't
even do we even know for sure that he's
going to play
would he not be a guy who's no i'm
sitting out again and maybe someone will
pick me up next year
he's mercurial so i don't know but
man that stay with the jets i mean what
what was that what is the lasting memory
of that i don't even know
well it's just a 17-game version of uh
riding on the cocktail napkin you don't
want to be there anymore so
it's that you know i don't want to be
the rb of the nyj
it's kind of really what it is but he
has tweeted out that uh
that he's got something to prove and i
think it would it would behoove him to
get out there right now and get on with
the team right now and show that he can
um you know i i think that would that
would absolutely make sense and i think
chris did you write down well-intended
joan of arc for a fantasy i sure did
okay did you write that one down i saw
it
i saw that you started scribbling yeah i
i picked up on that one too uh kyle
brandt here uh
on the on the rich eisen show all right
so uh i know you're an angry runs
uh individual um oh my god
uh derek henry stole the soul of
somebody last night did he not
comment and put it in his pocket that
that was that wasn't like remember where
you were
event in the sport of football like i'm
not saying it's the immaculate reception
or the philly special but i'm gonna
remember that for a long time and first
person experience with
i walked away from the tv for the hot
minute last night
doing something with the kids and i come
back and i look at my phone
and all right 50 different text messages
from people i knew
sat next to in high school or people i
work with and you don't know what
they're talking about
because the text messages were like oh
my god
and it was oh bleep oh i can't believe
it i'm like
what it's 20 20. we don't know what's
going on what are you people talking
about
finally i said oh my gosh all right
derek henry
threw someone out of the stadium like
uncle phil throws jazzy jeff out of the
house and that was
that was an unbelievably perfect storm
you know this underrated part of that
it made it so good and twitter loved it
so much
because it was josh norman josh norman
a known provocateur agitator
unapologetic you respect them
if that is anonymous bill's corner it
doesn't sing as much
true you know it had to be him
and it was so beautiful it was the it
was the
it was the black swan it was the a
perfect dance i've never seen a better
stiff room i don't think i can think of
one well i i was telling the story in
the first hour of the show kyle
that uh i was sitting at my desk and uh
at home
you know just taking notes and doing
stuff and being on twitter and just
generally hiding from my children and um
i saw that moment now and oh like
literally made that noise like oh
you know it was one of those moments uh
and then the first thing i thought of
was that
uh you know josh norman ran with the
bulls in pamplona
and i went and i got that photograph
saying that that's how he was preparing
for derek henry i mean literally that's
what was happening
that's literally that's a big ball
running is a big bull coming at you and
you better jump over it or run away
like literally those guys in the white
jumpsuits and the red scarves just get
the hell out of there but notice
you don't try to tackle the ball you he
literally
messed with the bull and got the horns
it was
i know what you mean by the sound that
you made yeah the equivalent of that
thing
is that stiff arm that derek henry threw
it was really like watching a dramatic
knockout in boxing or maybe mma like i
remember when
lennox lewis was fighting haseem rakmon
and it was just one of these
massive overhand rights when everybody
just starts going to the egg
exits before he goes to the canvas right
that was what we got from derek henry it
was beautiful that's why i love this
game
kyle brandt here on the rich eisen show
uh five weeks in
and uh the story of the 2020 season i'm
gonna go
macro on you right now kyle we're fine i
don't
forget about covid i won't talk about
just football here i don't know the
football story of the 2020 season
is what through five weeks of this
campaign
what do you think i i think
i think it's rogers i think it's the
packers
but don't you already feel rich like
we're gonna get
russell versus rogers part nine like
it's it's
i know that it's october these two teams
are so good
the two quarterbacks are so good they've
played eight times
they're four and four against each other
the home team has won
every single time i think as well as
those teams are playing in
purely non-coveted story lines it's the
two of them
because listen the blooms off the rose
on the bills now that might have been
the story if they went last night
uh the chiefs have learned that they
like xerxes
can bleed and now we got you know the
raiders are fascinating but i'm just
gonna right to the cream of the crop
i'm gonna go right to the two best teams
we see right now and i think it's it's
it's green bay seattle uh you and i have
both talked to
rogers or throughout our careers
including this season
when i last did i posed them a question
directly i said aaron you've dominated
the nfc north
so badly you there's no competition i
said who is your rival do you have a
rival in the nfl
peyton had brady and on and on he said
well you know i've played matt stafford
the most
no no that stafford is not your rival
and who's your rival
and he didn't give an answer and i said
i think it's russ because yeah
we've had some good games it was almost
a reluctance to admit it but that's the
one
and i hope they meet in the nfc title
game i know that before that they don't
meet at all
uh in the regular season interesting
enough uh but it's rogers and brady
coming up i can't wait i mean what a
piece of filet mignon week six man
rogers and brady coming up 212's and you
know obviously
uh brady having fun with his uh senior
moment by uh
putting lebron on on his body in the
number four congratulating him on his
fourth title all that stuff you know
brady's taking it all in
um and uh you know hopefully for him he
can get godwin back and everybody
somewhat
uh you know moderately healthy i can't
wait for that one
that's going to be amazing this weekend
the only thing that that i would like
better than the bucks get into the super
bowl with brady
we've talked about this is is the
patriots box super bowl like
that's that is the sporting event that
is better than the balboa drago on
christmas day
in in the ussr that's the biggest
sporting event of our time and the
patriots are mysterious now all of a
sudden i feel like we haven't seen him
in a long time but that's the one i want
and i think brady will get up from the
turf that khalil mack was slamming him
on now
by the way that was one of my favorite
uh pieces of video from week five was
when uh when he was sacked by khalil
mack and brady didn't know who sacked
him and then he saw it was mack and he
kind of like rolled his other kind of
like again
like he kind of gave tristan worse a
look like you know can we can come on
bro
can we can we can we get a little help
like literally that was one of my
favorite pieces of video that i saw on
the weekend uh but all that said
um you know uh you did say that you like
the steelers before the season
they are four and oak chase claypool was
another guy who memed
the brady number four for the number of
touchdowns that he had
yesterday i i kind of pounded the table
on my four downs that big ben is not
getting
mvp talk and he like russell wilson also
has
never received a vote for most valuable
player in his career
never and uh maybe it's time to start
pounding the table for him being an mvp
because
unless everybody thinks his consolation
prize of not being part of this
conversation is the comeback player of
the year award he's going to get
well yeah i mean that's at this point
who knows that's that may go to alex
smith
um there's going to be a lot of
competition at the nfl honors but what
you bring up
for mvp is fascinating because we it's
it's a little like the royal rumble you
get the couple of guys in the ring early
and you know we had russ and we had
rogers i think josh allen might have
just gotten thrown over the top rope by
big john stud he might be out
but you get the other guys who are
running in who roethlisberger and
bryan tannehill is leading an undefeated
team and running for touchdowns and
beating the bills and throwing
i mean he looks great too so this thing
is is not going to be
patrick mahomes throws 50 touchdowns and
runs away with it or lomar runs for 12
000
yards it's gonna beat down to the last
month and we got some heavyweights in
there throwing punches
i agree with you about pittsburgh i
thought they were gonna win the super
bowl
before rich we got to the chase clay
pool experience
which is delightful a six foot four
canadian receiver
the only battle that's going on i see
with him everybody likes him there seems
to be a lot of discussion about what his
nickname should be
and i would only uh ask your thoughts on
it please i i saw one suggestion i
adored
which was if calvin johnson was megatron
this guy being last name claypool is
optimus primus
uh which i really really liked i know
that canadian roots are calling a
mapletron
and then they say when he goes to the
red black and yellow striped jerseys
he could be a bumblebee so there's a lot
of decepticon stuff going on but i love
the primus thread
okay uh i will go with the chase drill
oh boy the chase jerome kyle
don't entertain this for once let me i i
i i can't understand the word rich is
saying well again i'm trying to help you
richard no okay
so i i i've yes the chase troll um
matt the natural matt ryan didn't want i
then went to matt stafford uh not
knowing at the time that they were
best friends that i was offering uh matt
stafford the sloppy seconds that matt
ryan did not
want i then went back to matt ryan again
he still rejected that
and then i called patrick mahomes and i
said how about the patrol
he laughed via text and said no
thank you i then went back to matt ryan
again you know this is the letterman uh
style of humor to take something beat it
up and then beat it to death
uh this was matt ryan's response you got
to move on you gotta move on he told me
to move on
um so i won't move on from just the fill
in the blank
charol uh i could go claytra you know we
could do that
uh poultry did you ever try the doctoral
never tried it never tried it that does
sound like a nice tasty treat at fat
tuesdays
you know like you can get that that
could pack a wall up by the way xerxes
blood might be my next fantasy team name
i wrote
that one down that's a good one that's a
good
game
so i i'd like that mapletron is not a
bad one i kinda
you know you gotta you gotta know that
he's canadian and you gotta know that
he's tall
you know that's that's that's the
problem with that one yeah he likes and
he likes the attention
typically when i think of canadian
rooted wide receivers who draw attention
to themselves all day long i think of
nate burleson
but there's a new guy here
ladies and gentlemen that is good
morning football shots fired right there
i do
think though that that that in
the halftime segment of last night's
game bill cower gave
nate the credit for angry runs yeah
did you hear that i think what happened
is i think nate
texted him something about angry runs
and then bill did his best to
uh credit me with it but listen
i'll take it this is me screaming in my
leaky basement about guys running over
each other so the fact that it goes to
the cbs broadcast center and bill cower
is talking about angry runs it's pretty
awesome rich so before i let you go sir
you you dropped serious breadcrumbs last
week saying that you were you had just
gotten off the phone for this week's pod
interview ten questions with kyle brent
spotifying
the ringer uh of one of the greatest
movies of all time one of your favorite
movies ever
and a significant star we all guessed
and it turns out to be i give you the
floor
your guest this week well i didn't pull
the rug out
i didn't do the the smart ass thing and
say hey it's
it's jean-claude van damme from
bloodsport no this is real
i promise you there'd be no joke and on
the most recent episode of ten questions
is the great great tim robbins
from the shawshank redemption which is
how i qualified one of the most beloved
movies ever
and one of the lead actors of that the
lead actor and i got to tell you
unbelievably cool guy and if you eat up
shawshank like we all do
you gotta hear tim robbins talking about
how at night during the shoot
he and morgan freeman would sit around
and barbecue
and uh you know as he put it enjoy
certain illegal activities and i said
hold on a second so you're telling me
andy and red are sitting around
you know smoking doobies and eating
chicken wings and then he said and
we had a basketball court where i was
living and the guy
clancy brown who plays byron hadley
would come over and we'd play basketball
andy versus hadley you guys are both
like seven feet tall how did the games
go
and we got into it and i was in heaven
and robin's was amazing
okay so uh many questions based off of
that i don't have ten
i don't know if we have time left for
that but sure uh are are you saying did
somebody post up morgan freeman
is that what you're saying or he didn't
play the basketball i think it might
have been william sadler who was going
on freeman and because freeman is good
from the perimeter
but hadley and dufresne were on the low
post
and i have pieced together who i think
would be my uh my shawshank starting
fives please
if i had to have one and i i would be
i'd be thrilled to share it with you
please if i was going to make a starting
five from the crew it's
in my point guard i got young tommy who
comes in with the sideburns and has to
learn how to read
um i got haywood uh haywood at the
shooting guard mouthy good stroke
byron byron headley's gonna be my center
my man in the middle
red is gonna be my small forward i think
he's tall he shows athleticism with the
baseball glove and then andy dufresne is
our power forward
with boggs the sixth man coming off the
bench
some aggression off the bench
all right now give me the starting fire
from the green mile and who wins
oh well look you that's i gotta go all
day you got
you all you even need anything aft after
coffee the coffee you can just sit there
in the middle of and just eat up all the
paint coffee
drink of course that is and then you
take uh percy
percy is going to be the agitator
because he just annoys the hell out of
everybody
and then i want mr jingle the magic
mouse running the point guard
and after that we're going to beat
everybody by 30. it's going to be like
the dream team against estonia we'll
just run it up on everyone
we should do all stephen king adapted uh
films uh starting five and uh
like do some sort of stephen king
madness and let's go
i love it you know in the brits you
don't need to get us started you know
we'll do the running man and our front
court of whitman price and haddad will
all be all stars you know that
the problem is is what whitman price and
haddad are we getting the real one are
the ones that have been put on the
island to
hide the entire construct of the
dystopia
what are we doing you remember them on
the maui sun
whitman price and haddad
what it's fantastic
what do you got to go for chris before
we go we can't
we can't sleep well also we just got to
bring it up i mean i hate to go down
this road with you but it is the
anniversary of the steve bartman play
where were you what do you remember
about that moment
i remember it vividly and this is one of
my most vivid sports memories of my life
uh
in the steve bartman play which i
believe was in october of 2003
i was on the set uh of nbc's days of our
lives
playing philip kariakis i was doing a
scene with my father victor kariakis
who was of course played by john aniston
the real life father jennifer aniston
and we couldn't watch the game and the
camera guys
on their little monitors they would get
like a tv feed on the big of their giant
cameras they had then
and i remember the cubs were way up and
i said this is going to be incredible we
got we're going to the world series it's
going to be amazing i've been a cop fan
my whole life
and the guy on camera one ever after
every take of the scene that i kept
messing up would say
another run for the marlins another run
he would lean over and he said it's not
but it's not good it's not good
what the hell you talking about is not
good let's close this thing go to the
series
finish the scene finally i was terrible
in the scene i was just like john
anderson was just carrying me
and i find out what happened and um
i never forget i watched that i was
devastated and then later that night on
sportscenter our our friend dan patrick
got baba bowie by captain jenks this
crazy
night like sands through the hourglass
that's right oh my gosh
what are you saying you didn't think
that would be the answer to that not
it's today 17 years ago today oh
no that's crazy honestly one of the one
of the true
black eyes on the chicago sports fan
base i genuinely believe that was a
terrible
pathetic display and uh i i actually am
kind of ashamed of that as a chicagoan
what they did to that guy
moises to lose reaction didn't help but
that was human the worst part about him
we don't need to go down the hill
it was game six yes they had carrie wood
going in game
seven a game in which carrie wood hit a
home run
and they still couldn't win the game so
don't put it all on barton wherever he
is in his
subterranean bunker in the north suburb
somewhere leave that man alone alex
gonzalez had the double play ball
right there and he went through the
wickets and also by the way buckner
everybody thinks buckner played it was
game seven of the 86 series it was game
six
so there's there's many different ways
to go uh
ten questions with kyle brandt uh on
spotify and ringer i will definitely get
that tim robbins episode because i'm
sure you you had to go in the bull
durham direction a little bit
as well with him
field of dreams and major league and he
took a run at it buddy that nuke
looked back and buzzed one fantastic ten
questions with kyle brandt podcasts were
uh on spotify and the ringer and of
course good morning football 7 a.m every
single day
love our chats every wednesday i'll text
you to that i'll say it again uh thank
you that's the best
i look forward to it every week right
back at you that's kyle bryant everybody